today our classic car expert christophe
bauer is behind the wheel of a 1935
bentley three-and-a-half liter Park Ward
arrow saloon in the early 30s British
luxury brand Bentley was in crisis the
legendary Bentley boys may have won the
24 Hours of LeMans five times but even
they couldn't save the car maker from
going into receivership
what's that I don't Kristof says in 1931
Bentley have its back to the wall and
needed a financial backer just before
the firm was to be taken over by
aircraft engine maker Napier an unknown
bidder acquired Bentley for 125 thousand
pounds the bidder turned out to be
competitor in our tribal Rolls Royce
that hoped Bentley sporty image would
help it win over younger customers while
getting the superior Bentley eight
leader off the market the first product
of their liaison was this car here the
Bentley three and a half liter the first
rolls Bentley was produced in the
English city of Derby Rolls Royce had
been making its entry-level model the
rolls-royce 2025 there since 1929
[Music]
Christophe tells us that the Bentley
three-and-a-half leader was the first
Darby Bentley technically it was based
on the pretty conservative rolls-royce
2025 so they had to make quite a few
modifications before it fit Bentley
sports car image the chassis is much
lighter and the straight six engine was
souped up rolls-royce might not have
talked much about horsepower but Bentley
sure did its technicians were able to
eke 110 horsepower out of 3.7 liters of
cubic capacity christophe says they
transformed a sluggish luxury sedan into
what became known as the silent sports
car while the Bentley three and a half
liter does have rigid axles its
adjustable hydraulic shock absorbers
allow this 1.7 tonne juggernaut to offer
a good mix of comfort and sportiness the
precise steering and huge servo assisted
drum brakes make the Bentley feel like a
race car
Christophe says that at the moment he's
traveling in comfort mode but that will
change quickly when he flips this cutoff
lever then the three and a half litre
really shows what it's made of
kristef says that classic coach work
reached its zenith in the 1930s back
then each luxury car was still delivered
directly to the coachbuilder as a
rolling chassis complete with engine
radiator and gearbox the coach builder
then created a custom body based on the
clients wishes this three and a half
liter prophets from Bentley slim
radiator grille which looks sporty and
more elegant than the clunky ones made
for rolls-royce it also made this
aerodynamic design possible christophe
thinks the wonderfully streamlined rear
end is an absolute highlight this model
called the Aero saloon was designed by
English aircraft engineer sir Roy fed
just three were built by the coach
builder park board in Williston making
it a real rarity cavitate over the
course of the 1930s rolls-royce took
over Park Ward which made bodies for
close to half of all the Darby Bentley's
produced the coach builder fashion the
open t'rar the sedan kakou pay and this
version the sports saloon each vehicle
is special but not really one-of-a-kind
like most coach builders Park Ward
created standard styles that had
modified only slightly to suit clients
wishes christophe says that under the
hood you'll find a prime example of
engine tuning 1930 style the super
reliable straight-6 engine has just
under 3.7 liters of capacity to improve
performance the Bentley version had a
higher compression ratio a sporty-er
camshaft profile and a cross flow
cylinder head which is fed by these two
su carburettors this combination
delivers a full 110 horsepower which was
quite something in 1935 and if that
wasn't enough starting in 1936 buyers
could order the brand-new four and a
quarter liter engine which produced a
whopping 130 horsepower
[Music]
he says you have to develop a feel for
shifting gears double de-clutch abit
employ a soft touch and you can switch
gears without stripping them but when
you get it going the car gets 150
kilometers an hour and is a good travel
companion even today no joke some
Bentley enthusiasts even drove around
the world in 80 days in a three and a
half liter Christophe says in its day
the three and a half liter was described
as combining the power of an express
train with a tranquility of a sailboat
today you might say it combines the
reliability and sportiness of a Bentley
with the uncompromising quality of a
Rolls and he has the numbers to prove it
of the 2422 Darby Bentley's ever built
some 70% are still around today that
alone makes the car a classic but
there's more as a remodeled Rolls Royce
this Bentley is one of the first
representatives of what's now known as
platform strategy
so for Christophe the Bentley three and
a half liter is definitely a milestone
in automotive history in the post-war
era Rolls Royce took badge engineering
to the extreme except for the emblems
and hood ornaments most Bentley's were
exact replicas of rolls-royce models
that only changed after the Volkswagen
Group acquired Bentley through its
purchase of rolls-royce motors in 1998
now Bentley is once again creating its
own vehicles and giving rolls-royce now
owned by BMW a run for its money
[Music]